[music]
>> The second last participant
third last one participant didn't give
his expectations. Maybe he didn't have
expectation or maybe the list was too
long.
The second last is Muhammad Imran Fazal.
The longer it is that it came down lower
in the list.
Number one, inshallah, I would want to
learn how to dissolve the fundamentals
of other religions
without hurting anyone's sentiments
about it in a very respectful and
meaningful way.
I'm sorry.
You will not be doing this year.
Why? I'll tell you.
Your expectation, inshallah, I would
want to learn how to dissolve the
fundamentals of other religions without
hurting anyone's sentiments about it in
a very respectful and meaningful way.
Why will he not learn this year? Can
anyone give the reply?
I repeat it twice.
Why will he not be able to learn here
how to dissolve the fundamentals of
other religions?
Yes, brother. Can you pass on the
microphone?
What you mean I know.
What your intention is I know.
But the words are Alhamdulillah, what
I've learned the fundamentals of
different religions is tawhid, what I've
learned from your lectures.
>> if you dissolve tawhid
how can you be a da'i?
You should tell I will learn here how to
convince them that the fundamentals are
tawhid. You understand?
I know what your intention is. You
wanted to tell that I want to dissolve
the wrong thinking, but the words say
here dissolve the fundamentals of other
religions
without hurting them.
With hurting them also you should not.
Correct?
I know your intention.
I want to correct it.
Because the fundamental of every
religion is tawhid.
To remind them of the fundamentals of
other religions, which is tawhid.
Correct?
Yes, brother Imran. Are you convinced?
We'll deal with that, inshallah.
We'll be dealing with the fundamentals
of other religions, and you'll come to
know I will teach you how to convince
them to go back to the fundamentals
rather than dissolve it, inshallah.
Point number two, looking for
opportunities to practice our learnings
through internal and periodic debates,
exposure to public speech in front of
crowd. Inshallah.
Once
I mean, I remember that
last training program I conducted more
than 16 years back in 1999.
Amongst one of the participants was a
Malaysian.
Also a Christian revert like how some
are here.
Brother Muhammad Ayub, do you know him?
He was
a Christian missionary.
And he had the title IFS.
International Forgiver of Sins.
In Christianity, you have authority you
can forgive sins in this locality. You
can forgive sins in this city. You can
forgive sins in this country. He was
International Forgiver of Sins.
International means he was based in
Germany.
He was a Malaysian. He was a Christian.
He had the post of International
Forgiver of Sins.
And these people are trained.
They are trained thoroughly in how to
speak. But when he came and spoke on the
stage of IRF, that time the stage was
small.
Very small stage.
The size of the auditorium was
350 square feet, 35 square meter.
This is 10,000 square feet,
1,000
square meter.
You multiply
30 times bigger.
The whole
of this auditorium we had
was small part of the stage.
The stage is covering actually more than
half of the floor.
On that small stage of IRF,
he was shivering.
And he was saying, "All my training went
to the dogs."
All his training went to the dogs. He
said, "I've addressed large audiences,
but here speaking on the stage, you
know, but alhamdulillah, it was deep and
then went up again."
Then he realized the effectiveness that
was there because that training is not
based on hug. This training is based on
hug. The difference.
So, inshallah,
may Allah give you the opportunity
to be able to speak
effectively.
Effectively is the most important word,
inshallah.
Expectation number three, I would like
one of the two weekly off to be on
Friday if possible, and also would like
to be able to do five times salah per
day on time. Hence, I expect the
schedule of a program to support that. I
would like one of the two weekly off to
be on Friday if possible, and also would
like to be able to do five times salah
per day
on time.
Yes, weekly off is Friday. And I expect
even if it's not a Friday, you have to
pray five times.
So, how does this
Or they're two different expectations?
Mean this training program you like
that one weekly off should be Friday. It
is, masha Allah.
The emphasis on the schedule.
That you wanted the schedule to be such
a way in a way that it is facilitating
all these week off and And if it is not?
Well, I was just expecting that from
the training program. If not, I would
have requested it anyway.
I'm asking you a question.
That
if your expectation is not met, if the
Dawah training program doesn't give time
for salah, that training program is not
worth attending.
It is like you're telling me, "Okay, I
will come to have lunch with you as long
as you don't serve pork."
If you tell that to a practicing Muslim,
he'll feel offended.
What do you mean? I'm going to serve
alcohol and pork?
You understand, no? So, we're are going
to a Dawah training, that means you have
not done your homework.
That means
you have not done your homework on Dr.
Zakir Naik and neither have you done
your homework on IRF.
And without doing homework, you know,
you are going to give 50 days, 45 days,
it's not advisable. Actually, sir, there
was one other line I had in that email
that I haven't attended any Dawah
programs and I really do not know what
to expect and hence these were some of
the things that came to my mind.
>> If the Dawah training program does not
give you time to offer salah on time,
it's not worth attending.
It may be the best program in the world.
That means it's an un-Islamic training
program. Can't be a Islamic Dawah
training program. Salah is the most
important.
It's the most important.
If you join IRF, it's compulsory that
every person they have to offer salah on
time in Jamaat in the mosque.
On time in Jamaat in the mosque.
The sawab that you get in the mosque is
multiple time more. In IRF, it is
compulsory unless if you go on outdoor
assignment.
Compulsory.
One of the requirements to join IRF is
to keep a beard. Compulsory. Preferably
one fist.
Minimum we say 1 cm so it can be seen.
But preferably one fist.
Wearing the cap, wearing a cap is not
fard in Islam, but
it's a sunnah. Wearing trousers above
the ankle it's a fard.
So, when in an organization where
wearing the trousers above the ankle is
a fard, I don't know of any Islamic
organization in the world. They may be,
maybe Allah Alam. I have traveled to
different parts of the world. I don't
know a single Dawah organization in the
world which makes it compulsory for its
employees
to keep a beard and wear trousers above
the ankle. I don't know of any. Not even
in Saudi Arabia.
Even in our school, we have mashallah
more than 450 employees in Bombay alone.
It is alhamdulillah one of the largest
Islamic Dawah organization in the world,
alhamdulillah.
In terms of number of people
working.
So, you cannot expect. You have to
inquire.
Before submitting your application, if
you doubt it can't come in your
expectation, it can come into your
inquiry list.
Is it clear? So, in future if you're
going for a training program, it
shouldn't be expectation. Uh if you say
I would expect to become a five-time
namazi, that's a different thing. I
would want to become regular in prayer,
that's different. But, you can't expect
that you will have a Friday off, and
Friday off is preferable, not
compulsory. Here we have a Friday off,
alhamdulillah. Praying Jumu'ah salah is
a must, alhamdulillah.
So, that expectation is not
by doing the course.
If they allow you to pray, they are
doing a favor, it's a requirement.
So, this will not come in your
expectation, it should come in your
inquiry list.
Point number four, inshallah, good halal
food, safe and clean place to stay.
Inshallah, halal food is there. Good
food is subjective.
I was telling yesterday to the
foreigners, what's good for me may not
be good for you.
To the foreign participants, and 10 of
them are from the Oriental
line. Six are from Malaysia, two from
Singapore, one from Indonesia, one from
Japan. So, 10 people of the participants
are from Oriental. So, I asked Asif
Naik, who's my nephew, that try and get
some Oriental food.
He said, "Taste." I said, "What will I
do testing it?
Most probably I won't like it. You're
asking the wrong person. You can ask
Oriental person. Ask a Malaysian or
Indonesian to taste it. Even if I say
yes, it has no value. Even if I say no,
it's no value. Most probably I'll say
no." So, he said that will I send a
sample
to your home. I said, "What is the use?
Correct? Because I'm not expert in that
field. And personally, I don't like I've
had Oriental food.
So, good is
subjective. Halal, yes, it has to be.
Again, you inquiring whether you'll get
halal food is an inquiry. It cannot be
an expectation.
If you come to know that there is a
course where halal food is not served,
you have to make arrangements for your
own halal food. But Islamic organization
giving haram food,
that means you haven't done your inquiry
on that organization.
Safe and clean place to stay.
This is a question which I have to,
though I didn't want to
tell in detail.
Point number four, good halal food, safe
and clean place to stay.
Good food is subjective, halal inshallah
good. Safe and clean, safe place.
Some people don't like staying in
buildings. It's very safe.
We're talking about Mumbai, right? What
is Mumbai?
I've heard a lot of things about Mumbai
that it's not really safe. You know,
Mumbai
in the cities of India, it doesn't come
as Yeah, Delhi, you say yes.
In the most dangerous cities, Bombay is
considered one of the safest cities.
And there was a survey done in Bombay,
which is the safest locality? It is
Dongri where organization IRF is.
For the women, they did a survey, which
is the safest locality for women?
Because we are in the hub of the Muslims
in Bombay.
It's safe.
Good halal food, clean place to stay.
I didn't want to comment on this
question, but I'm commenting because
it's an expectation.
So, it's very important that if you want
to do something for Islam and if you can
check as I told you something in
interview, sometimes you don't.
And it was told very clearly that there
were certain criteria we had kept
for selection
of the participants.
And based on that criteria,
when
Brother Kaleem took the interview,
fortunately or unfortunately,
amongst the pure Indian pure Indian
means Indian resident none was selected.
There are two types of Indians, Indian
resident and non-resident Indian,
meaning Indians staying abroad.
So, amongst the Indian non-residents,
only two qualified.
One was my son.
He stays in Saudi Arabia, so he's an
NRI.
And one more person who was from
Holland, he's not here.
I'll tell you later on.
Then I told them, "Okay, when we are
having the course, why not we have a
parallel room?"
So, while this training is going on,
there are other Indians sitting in a
parallel room, which many of you may be
aware.
Now, these people, by default,
did not qualify in the normal criteria
for being selected as a participant for
the IDTP.
As a general policy, we asked to all the
people who applied,
"You want to be a full-time dahi?"
And almost all of them said, "Yes." Then
we also asked the question,
"Then would you like to work in IRF
as a full-time employee?" And
alhamdulillah, more than 80% of the
foreigners
and more than 80% of the Indians said,
"Yes."
Not that we wanted to employ them.
But I asked the question, "Why? If you
want to be a full-time dahi, are you
willing to work in the organization?"
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allahu Akbar.
Allahu [music]
Allahu
Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah,
Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah,
Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah,
[music and singing] Allah, Allah, Allah,
Allah, Allah, Allah, Allah.